hello everyone welcome back
to the collider interviews youtube
channel where we have
zoe's extraordinary playlist star skylar
aston with us i feel like i should ask
you how you're doing and stuff but
oh my god this season is so good i'm
obsessed with your show i
did not know how you guys were gonna
raise the bar after season one but
you do and i'm excited to get into all
the details with you
i am so excited to get into those
details with you i have answers
i'm looking forward to very particular
answers right now so just for
for everybody out there so you know
what's coming your way in this video
right here we're going to talk about
the entire season of zoe's extraordinary
playlist season two of course
minus the finale so make sure you're
caught up to that point
all right let's kind of start at episode
two here in in honor of the fact that
max and mo's uh business and their uh
professional partnership
really took off and was very successful
let's go back to some icebreakers give
me two truths and a lie right now
for me yeah holy crap or not i see i see
what's happening
okay if i can't think during then you
look like oh well that's obviously why
he was like doing it
okay um all right ready
i am currently building a deck right now
at my place
um i play the guitar and
my little league team was undefeated and
there's a plaque outside
my um town for that very little league
team
the guitar feels obvious to me but one
and three feel totally possible
i'm gonna lean towards one being the lie
and you having help building this deck
oh
well whoops i guess i played it wrong
i'm definitely having help to build the
deck
but i am building the deck the lie is
the guitar i don't know how to play the
guitar
i i don't know why because you just
assumed because you're looking at
i i thought people would just assume
it's like when i say i'm putting in a
deck like i'm not putting it in
by the way like i've helped but no i
definitely
have someone do it i've just seen so
much of your work
and know how talented you are in the
musical department i fee i feel like
there's something about piano and guitar
specifically that makes it feel like you
know instrument number one for
someone who is very skilled in that
department correct i know i've always
wanted to play the guitar
um i guess my fingers weren't ready for
the calluses
since i tickle the ivories more i always
wish i could i played guitar and drums
and i guess i wish i could build the
deck on my own but alas
also i'm so impressed and flattered that
you think it was even possible that i
could do such work
it's hard it's hard not to i'm not
leaving the icebreaker thing
yet let's do it let's do a round of hilo
give me one high from the filming of
season two and then one low
and maybe how you guys overcame that low
there was so many let's get loud
and one of the songs in the finale big
group number
at maximo were such highs for me
um because there was just so many people
in a room and it felt like a musical and
of course everyone was tested and you
know figured out
um but it just felt like a simulation of
doing a musical like a real like a
theater musical again i
was looking at someone's eyes and just
doing the choreography to them and
finding the next partner you're supposed
to partner up with
it was so fun um really joyful
that was definitely a high one of the
lows
um was so lame but like
it's so cold in vancouver at times and
i'm
always working outside on the coldest
days like the coldest
most biting days again the scene in
a scene in the finale was one of the
coldest days i've ever been a part of
and we're getting this beautiful
lighting shot so we shot it at sunrise
and then another really cold day was in
episode nine i'm having coffee
with zoey and she's trying to guess why
i was singing the demi lovato song
and the biggest struggle was me to um
open the sugar packets in the coffee and
just look like a human being would like
just like a relaxed human being and of
course in the scene i'm not supposed to
be
really struggling with any emotion or
anything like that so i couldn't even
lean into that
also like you know tears are streaming
down my face but not in a good way i'm
supposed to be casual
um so yeah i'd say i'd say just just the
cold
i am the biggest baby in the cold so
absolutely no judgment coming from me
right now once i start shivering it's
just
awful i mean it's so embarrassing like
jane's just like coming up to me and
like
putting her hands on my shoulders and
i'm just like this is so
all the wardrobe people do you want
another hot shot do you need
and they're like do you want some long
underwear i'm like already wearing it i
mean
it was just so bad i feel your pain and
the point is it doesn't read on screen
whatsoever
i am happy to hear that actually when
when the cut was coming in uh austin's
like by the way episode nine looks great
as we were filming like episode 11 or 12
i was like
the one scene all i need to know do i
look like a human
or not a human and he's like human so
mission accomplished
you brought up uh doing theater
how how again do you shoot these uh the
heart songs it's a mix of
of pre-recorded and live singing right
right well uh it depends on like the
anyone was live the new york state of
mind reprise was live
i sang the ed sheeran song in episode 12
live
it's just like when you're kind of
standing around
you can probably get away with it
continuity wise to do especially when
you're moving a lot it would just not
sound great
so i'm always i'm always up there
singing like i'm matching my performance
no matter what
just so you get all the veins and the
breathing and the breath like you're not
i'm not
fully miming singing um actually
sometimes i get into trouble because
um i as an actual singer don't open my
mouth a lot like in real life
so i'm legitimately doing what i would
do and then charlie alderman who's a
musical director on broadway and is our
musical director
on set always tells me to kind of
exaggerate certain vowels and
and and and look more real but i'm just
like i am doing the real thing
um but yeah that's kind of our that's
kind of the way we do it as far as the
vocals and the choreography
you know one or two rehearsals before
the day and and we just kind of whip it
up
i i was wondering if you had a
preference between
doing it live or pre-recorded because i
happen to have been re-watching
the movie les miz for another interview
and it got me thinking about
how unique that process was so it's like
if you did a movie like that would you
prefer to be doing all those songs
live on set or have the pre-record
look i think that like a lot of times
especially early on
earlier on on zoe's they'd be like you
want to just like try one live and i'm
like
no because and by the way i did it
anyway
and it ended up being getting in the
show like anyone was something we did
the pre-record a couple times and we did
literally two takes live and
or three takes tops but you know and
that's the one they ended up using but
like
um the only reason why i say no is
because i'm like hey there's so much
infrastructure that goes into doing
something live i mean like
you need to kind of be ready to do that
and not even so much like warm up your
voice just like make sure it's right
there's so many things that kind of
contribute to a tape going wrong camera
wise
and just everything technically you kind
of want to make sure it's it's set up
for that
um if we're outside like no chance we're
doing it live just the street noise
you'll never you'll never get it done so
it's it's less about like can you pull
it off and just more about like every
other department and element that goes
into recording sound
um so yeah no we've done it
i'm down if it was if it was a like a
movie like blame is that was designed
for that
absolutely that's that's my bread and
butter i mean that's my
first love is theater so like i would i
would love to to do something like that
and
anytime we get to do that on the show
it's like a real reward
with all of those production challenges
in mind that you just named
is there any particular heart song from
season two that
posed an especially unusual challenge
that you guys had never experienced
before
a challenge in the preparation was in
episode two
the whole medley of um take me out to
the ball game and i'll make love to you
and
into the scene which then leads to zoe
and max's song a moment like this
and i just think that because it was a
whole act of television it was just like
a play
and so we just needed to rehearse it and
tune it and
and it really played well at the table
read but
then when when we got on our feet it
wasn't as clear
because i would think that i was doing
something that was conveying my anxiety
but turns out
since i'm singing boys to men it's
actually sounding a little smoother or
seeming a little bit more comfortable so
like
finding the physical manifestations of
that anxiety and selling it
i was just like hoping that people would
understand what was going on
because it's also like there's a bit of
um you know
performance anxiety literally and i'm
talking about
singing performance anxiety but also we
are in the bedroom so it's like
i hope people are not thinking it's that
sort of thing um
especially while my pants are around my
ankles so like just selling what i'm
nervous about and that i'm trying to
stuff this song back in my heart
and um and just kind of cracking that
code and it was really fun
and um i mean we of course had
our director anja adams and we and mandy
moore our choreographer and our
creator austin winsberg weighing in
heavily on that but
jane is such an asset because jane
is zoe and uh obviously sees everything
through her point of view
and if it doesn't make sense to her or
she's not buying it or not understanding
something um she's pretty vocal about it
because she cares
and it's always met with success because
um she's always right and uh and she was
in this case like if i was doing
something that i thought had been
working and she's like i don't know why
he's doing that
it was so helpful to have her at
rehearsal and since it was early on
she was actually involved in the
rehearsal process and wasn't uh
you know working every single day and
every hour like jane always is that's
one of my favorite things to ask about
just
the idea of being number one on the call
sheet for a huge ensemble show like this
and
you know not just being number one and
delivering good work in that position
but also the way that you influence the
people around you and the environment on
set and it sounds like she's a major
asset in that department
beyond she's the best she's the absolute
best
all right let's get into that flashback
episode i guess the first the first
thing i have to bring up for that is
i've never had
more respect for max throughout this
entire show than when he chose to
prioritize building the jurassic park
t-rex
that's right i've been stacking bricks
since i was five
i just i have to know did you actually
build any of it and did you get to keep
it
i didn't get to keep it um
i built i was what i said was and we
actually
i think in the edit it was it was up
here anyway so you didn't even get to
see too much of my handiwork but
uh i wanted to make sure that at least
like i could put the big pieces on to
the big pieces so i had a couple little
like
addition and subtract action that i
would do for continuity each
take so i got good at like finishing the
rubik's cube you know but not
like doing the rubik's cube that was the
prop department of course
and um yeah i just loved his whole
attitude that whole episode
that was definitely the part of the show
where my eye for continuity was just
like it made my head feel like it wanted
to explode because i can't imagine doing
that scene multiple times
and deconstructing a lego where i have a
hard enough time building one once
yeah i mean i mean we could have done
the whole western switch where it's like
you know you do it and then you take one
out and it's fully completed but we were
actually
in real time like i think it was like a
bit of the tail and then the head
so it was just like a little bit of
torso to make it look defunct and then
building the torso and attaching the
finishing touch
these are the most important details
that everyone in addition to me wants to
know right now you have no idea how much
thought goes into the amount of glitter
on my face
uh cucumbers on my eyes and what kind
size cucumbers i mean that is one thing
about this show it's like we don't just
um
zero in on the musical aspects it's
everything i do love thinking about
all the production design and the level
of detail on that is there is there any
little detail in
uh maximos that you hope people catch
because it's so
beautifully decorated that it's hard not
to push pause and actually scan the room
a little more thoroughly
truly i think i did a um an internal
video that should be coming out
to someone's instagram whether it's
zoe's or lionsgate where i do a full-on
tour
because it's just the construction and
the geography of it even and like how it
works with the alleyways
and how that connects to the kitchen and
just the aesthetics i mean it's
got mo all over it but um the murals are
beautiful
um there are these really beautiful
framed like oil paintings on like on the
ceiling of the bar
so when you're in the bar you look up
there's just like beautiful frames
um that's one of my favorite parts um
also
in the finale we explore that uh second
level of maximos quite a bit
and i think in a season three we would
kind of play with that even more
um it's just it's just a beautiful space
our set designers so unbelievable and um
to kind of like be in that space from
its
drippy gross construction to
half done in episode five with you know
when i'm doing it was just one table at
the sage party and then
all the way through let's get loud and
now we're just living in that space and
having mary steve virgin's character in
there and just like
in the finale there's a huge group
number at maximo it's just it's just the
gift that keeps on giving and such a
i know austin and mandy were really
adamant that it felt like a space where
dance could could
could inhabit it and we've done that
quite a bit now our actual
like stage is humongous we have a huge
spark
spark point on one stage and then the
next stage over is all the houses and
apartments so it's the clark house and
max's apartment alice and andrew's
apartment
zoe's apartment mo's apartment and then
over
is our swing set which in season one we
use for like the engagement party
but uh maximo really took took hold of
it this year and then behind that
is where we kind of pop out you know the
therapist's office and um
all sorts of stuff it's it's it's really
it's really movie magic it's it's a big
production it is absolutely incredible
looking i have one more flashback
episode question for you before we go
into the finale here
so i know that throughout the season we
were already
learning a little more about max's past
but was there anything that happened in
that particular episode that maybe
i don't know filled a hole in the
character even for you that kind of made
you go
i don't know either like huh like that
makes sense that he would do a thing
like that
or maybe i'm so excited to know about
this quality and now dig into it even
more than i was doing before
i think like i think a bit of his false
bravado was really informative and
like his um carefree attitude in the
pilot when we meet him
he talks about how he's not management
material and he's kind of coasting at
spark point and
you know sees himself with the ceiling
but really informing that with like
his insecurities about his dad which you
know we of course touched on in present
day and will continue to in the future
so that will inform the character even
more so that this has been something
that's been a part of him forever
but what i really appreciated is just
the dynamic between zoe and max it was
really unexpected
i always thought if there was an origin
story
it would be they met they clicked they
finished each other sentences
you know they were instantly making fun
of other people
you know but to see that there was this
kind of meat bad uh you know not a meat
cute i thought that that was really
fascinating and that they actually had a
bit of a journey to go towards each
other
um and to cover all that ground in
episode 12 was really a blast i
i appreciated not giving a crap about
what zoe had to offer in
those first few scenes and really more
focused on her lunch and the frisbees
and just making fun of her and i think
that that's uh
i think that that's not the typical move
and i was i was happy to play along with
that he's a little bit more immature
a little bit more jovial that episode
was done so so well
especially how how well it then informs
going back and re-watching the material
with them but then also with what's to
come
in the next episode and speaking of
which this is the time where we say
goodbye to all of our viewers who have
not watched the season finale
of zoe's extraordinary playlist just in
case you haven't at this point
you could press play and stream it right
now on hulu so get on it
and then click over to the next video
where we continue the conversation